well listen you guys what a like wild
and poetic like last couple years you
two have been having uh let's start with
the fact that y'all have been busy on
the road this past year obviously
touring the record uh but now you guys
are um on the road with Ben Platt how's
it been going
Nicole that you
I mean you know we came from a past
where our music was widely known and we
were really young and then took a very
big break for music and now we've been
able to kind of integrate ourselves back
into the music scene and we're doing it
our way and we're having fun and we
enjoy the music we're putting out and
the fans love it and it feels really
good it feels really right and I think
this collaboration being able to tour
with Ben has been really special because
his fan base is very very
um in line with the way our fans think
and view music and I think a lot of it's
emotion based I mean he's a really
authentic performer and has a huge heart
and I think that that resonates with his
live audience and that's what Ali and I
try to convey on our live shows so it is
a really good fit from like an emotional
standpoint not to mention the fact that
Ben has said he has been a fan of your
guys's for so long I mean can you share
when you guys kind of first met and just
what the Vibes are like on the road with
Ben
well we met at a party it was a bafta
party
um a few years ago and he mentioned that
he was a big fan of take me which we
were we were like pleasantly surprised
by
um and then you know we've obviously
been able to kind of you know hang
backstage we did a dinner the other
night and we were just kind of you know
each asking each other things about our
careers because they are very different
but they're also similar in the
standpoint of like we both are actors
and we're both musicians
um and
you know it's just cool to see that
we've had very different uh trajectories
in our in our Artistry but we also all
started very young you know if you
started when he was quite Young on stage
and so we have this kind of cool common
ground that we share so obviously you
guys when you re-release uh the explicit
version of Potential Breakup Song
[Music]
I mean that nearly broke the internet
people were going so insane did it kind
of inspire you to maybe want to
re-record some other songs in the future
other plans to like re-record your
discography it inspired us to re-record
um two other songs from our past
chemicals reacting like whoa and we did
a cool collaboration
um with likewell with Bobby Brown which
was a really a really cool way to kind
of you know
take a nod from the past but also make
it kind of present with this new
production and it was like a new launch
of one of their um eye sticks so that
was actually really fun and a cool way
for us to call back to the old music but
I think you know I think we're in a
place where you know whenever you come
to a show you're always going to hear a
song or two from our past Ali I gotta
ask you because uh speaking of breaking
the internet uh you recently reunited
with your fill of the future castmates
and of course when people see a photo
like that first of all brings a bunch of
nostalgia but then everyone wants to
know is there a chance y'all will be
working together again whether it's a
reboot or in some other form
um we've never gotten a call to do a
reboot but I feel like most of us would
come back
um I would if if it made sense and and
most of the cast could reunite sure
um but I don't know I don't I don't know
if Phil had
um nearly as long of a
as long of a run as some of these other
shows that are getting reboots it makes
a lot of sense because it's a show
that's maybe been on for five six
seasons we only did two you know it was
it was quite short
um but you know the the fact that we're
all still friends and we're able to hang
out and catch up and see each other it
had been a a moment since I'd seen both
of them we always are like texting and
dming um but to actually being in person
is is another thing but um but it's
great you know it was a huge part of my
childhood and
um to be able to still have those
friendships that many years after is is
really special it was really cool to see
you guys all together I mean AJ did you
kind of have like a fangirl moment too
I did I wasn't at the launch but when I
saw them post the photo my heart I was
like oh my gosh this is my childhood
right I remember I mean I love feel the
future when it came out and I was so
proud of my sister as like a younger
sister going oh my gosh my sister's on
this Disney Channel show yeah and so for
me it was really sweet to see that photo
of them through together and to know
that it wasn't put together for like a
work reason AJ you know you surprised
people too when you revealed that you
and Ali were actually offered roles in
Hannah Montana do you guys ever think
about like what that would look like
like what that would have been like if
you guys did do that show
we've thought about it because how could
you not you know I said one of those
things where that show was massive and
and we had an opportunity to be a part
of it which I look at as a major
blessing I think Ali and I you know made
a decision
um as artists that I don't regret but
I'm also like wow that started something
for Miley that started something for
Emily like that was a huge moment in
their career and it was supposed to be
them yeah I do believe that it was meant
to be and and like AJ said you know
everything is is is for a reason and at
that point I think you were really
pivoting to focus on music and yeah we
were kind of you know turning away from
the channel and and not you know not
really spending our time as actors at
that moment in time no and and a little
worried that it would confuse people if
one of us was playing a pop star in a
show when we actually were working on
our band it would be like wait but what
band are you so for us it felt like the
right move but I would have never
usually told that story because it's
like who cares like anyone could say
that but once that came out and they
were talking the cast director about
like who you're like wait a minute in
consideration I was like but hold on
hold on
you're right everything does happen for
a reason though and still like I would
include you guys with the Hannah Montana
cast with the you know Camp Rock people
like you guys are in a unique Club you
know what I mean and did you see JoJo
posted that throwback pic with you and
the Jonas Brothers yeah yeah I mean do
you remember what that was from and also
what kind of memories does that bring
you when you see a photo I don't
remember what that was from maybe it was
like a maybe we were all playing a radio
show or something no it looks like we
were in a hotel room yeah I'm not sure I
actually don't remember
memories that I do remember very
specifically and then there's others
where I'm like that's just like a black
hole I don't I don't know where that's
from yeah it's iconic that photo is
Iconic oh thank you uh but I think part
of that is just having been in the
business for a long time you know
there's certain memories that you hold
on to and feel very significant in
others you're like yeah that's life you
sometimes forget what who you worked
with what for what you did that day and
it's just you move on it was a sweet
bottle though I was gonna say I saw
maren Morris comment on it this photo
needs to go up in the Smithsonian and I
think I I did someone pointed out that
comment to me and Tech
I was like well her version of what
should go on the Smithsonian is a bit
off but but thank you very much thank
you that is very sweet
[Music]